-Good evening, everybody,
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we are gonna get to the news.
Former Vice President Mike Pence
announced on Saturday
that he is ending
his presidential campaign,
and said, "This is not my time,"
but only because his time
is the 1950s.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden today
signed an executive order
regulating artificial
intelligence technology.
It's so stringent that he now
has to play himself
in Disney's Hall of Presidents.
[ Laughter ]
While speaking at
a campaign event yesterday
in Sioux City, Iowa,
former President Trump
mistakenly referred
to the South Dakota city
of Sioux Falls.
Well, that's it.
He's got to be done now, right?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, 91 felony charges
is one thing,
but you can't mix up
the Sioux.
According to a new survey,
75% of Americans believe
that democracy is at risk in
the 2024 presidential election.
And the other 25% is enough
to win the Electoral College.
[ Laughter ]
Vice President Kamala Harris
appeared last night
on "60 minutes,"
which means that rescuers
were finally able
to call off the search.
[ Laughter ]
Vice President Kamala Harris
said in a new interview
that her relationship
with President Biden is similar
to the one Biden had with
former President Barack Obama.
Oh, so,
you think you're friends,
and he thinks you're co-workers?
[ Laughter ]
Minnesota Congressman
Dean Phillips
announced on Friday
that he is launching
a primary challenge
to President Biden.
Now, if you're familiar
with Dean Phillips,
then thank you for watching,
Mrs. Phillips.
[ Laughter ]
Today was Ivanka Trump's
42nd birthday,
and I just think it's nice
she gets to spend it
with family.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new estimate
from "Forbes" magazine,
Taylor Swift
is now a billionaire,
which means that someone has
a difficult decision to make.
[ Laughter ]
"On one hand,
I want to see it.
On the other hand, billionaires
have too much money."
[ Laughter ]
-New York Congressman
George Santos
pleaded not guilty last week
to additional charges
and then winked so hard
it gave him a smoky eye.
[ Laughter ]
A 92-year-old man from Spain
recently completed
a 24-mile hike
of the Grand Canyon.
Said the man, "Last time
I was here, this was all flat."
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
the World Cheese Awards
were held last week,
and a blue cheese from Norway
won first place.
And it was all going great
until...
-I'm really happy for you.
I'mma let you finish.
[ Laughter ]
-Kanye.
Kanye, no.
That was the monologue,
everybody.
We're off and running.